these right here are the ows Pro open
ear headphones sent to us and sponsored
by Ola dance it's a new type of earbud
that's meant to finally solve the
decade-old problem of ear fatigue and
discomfort that comes with traditional
earbuds by not actually going into your
ear canals at all while at the same time
offering great sounding stereo audio due
to some unique software magic that I'm
going to explain in this video along
with answering a couple of big questions
just how comfortable are these compared
to traditional earbuds and do they
actually sound good enough for you to
make the switch the first thing I want
to start off with before getting into
those big questions is the specs because
these things are actually quite
impressive with just the buds alone they
give you a huge 16 hours of battery life
which basically destroys every other
mainstream pair of earbuds like Apple's
airpods and when you combine that with
the charging case it goes up to a total
of 58 hours which is absolutely insane
and they can be quick charged to give
you six hours of battery life in just 15
minutes of charging and yes this
charging case actually looks and feels
super nice having a soft closed hinge
design a convenient USBC charging port
on the back LED lights for battery life
on the front and it's also very slim
with a weight of only 73.6 grams and
even crazier is the rated standby time
which goes up to a crazy three years of
battery life if they're sitting in the
Box using Ola Dance's patented energy
lock technology so you don't have to
worry about battery drain when not in
use like with other earbuds but now
getting to the buds themselves they feel
amazing with a really soft silicon
rubber combined with a smooth high
quality ceramic skin eight layered
coloring coding which is included on the
white finish that I have here as well as
pink and green so they are incredibly
comfortable instead of going in your
ears they simply hook around your ear
and rest on top and they're very
lightweight as well sitting at only 13.8
grams so you can wear them for hours
while barely noticing them it's simply
incredible to have these on and have
nothing plugging your ear canal which
means absolutely zero fatigue or pain
after long listening sessions now these
also come with ipx4 water resistance
which makes them very suitable for
outdoor use like for working out or
jogging in the rain and the best part is
that unlike most earbuds the open ear
design means that you can still hear all
of your surroundings perfectly so if
you're going out for a walk or a jog you
can hear oncoming cars with no issues or
people while still listening to your
music even at full volume and in terms
of Technology the ows Pro come with
Bluetooth 5.3 and they actually support
multi-point connection for seamless
Multi-Device transition which a lot of
other earbuds don't have the ows Pro
also have two speakers and membranes
packed in which doubles the sound
pressure level and proves base
performance and reduces high frequency
Distortion providing a 360 degree
surround sound experience it also packs
dual chips with a primary chip and
amplifier to improve sound and it uses
their patented virtual bass 2.0
algorithm to improve the bass but now
moving on to the most unique feature by
far we've got to head into the Ola dance
app right here is the button for Focus
mode which is a form of noise
cancellation which at first I thought
was ridiculous because these don't even
go into your ear canals but I tried it
out and I was shocked that it actually
works and lowers the annoying low to
mid-range noise from the HVAC in our
office but at the same time you can
still hear someone talking to you in
your room so it's the perfect balance of
getting rid of some of the persistent
noise while not impacting conversations
now within the app you also have a bunch
of customization for both controls and
EQ so let's jump into the controls first
as you can see the ows Pro have a
physical button where you can slide to
adjust the volume click once to pause
and play Click twice to change songs
click three times to activate your voice
assistant and when you're getting a
phone call you can click once to answer
and twice to hang up or reject and all
these settings are fully customizable in
the app here's how the microphone sound
with that noise reduction technology let
me know what you think down in the
comment section below and as you've just
heard these have wind noise reduction
technology to help with microphone
clarity now moving over to the EQ
settings you have the choice of default
surging base and pure voice which is
great for audio books where you want to
hear voices clearly and of course you
can also customize the EQ with a range
of frequencies from bass to high notes
and then save that custom preset as for
my personal preference I found the
surging base mode to be the best if you
don't want to mess with the custom EQ
and now with all those specs and
features out of the way I want to start
answering the original questions
including Ola Dance's unique software
magic before I get into my own personal
thoughts first of all I already
mentioned the focus mode which actually
works really well for lowering
background noises which I didn't expect
to work at all since they don't actually
go into your ears so that was very
impressive but other than that the thing
that really impressed me is their base
algorithm which creates virtual bass
while using an open ear design which is
something that's incredibly hard to
achieve since bass naturally relies very
heavily on having a sealed area of air
that can move around to create That Base
effect and sound but somehow all it ants
is able to create Bass with a completely
open design so Props to them for that
now it definitely isn't nearing the
level of bass that you're gonna get from
a traditional sealed earbud design that
does actually create an enclosed area of
air for base but that's the entire point
of these headphones the main goal is to
not create a seal in your ear canals and
leave them completely free and
comfortable for very long listening
sessions especially for people who
struggle to wear in-ear earbuds because
they naturally experience more pain and
fatigue from regular earbuds these are
the perfect solution for people like
that as well as everybody else who just
wants to try something new and unique to
see if this is something that works for
them and the main reason for that is the
huge benefit of comfort so let's get
into answering the question of how
comfortable these are compared to
regular earbuds honestly these have to
be by far the most comfortable earphones
that I've ever used simply for the fact
that it doesn't touch your ear canal at
all since I personally experience ear
fatigue after a while of using even the
best in-ear earbuds as it almost feels
like my ear canals start to swell up and
hurt almost like my body is trying to
get me to take the earbuds out and let
my ears breathe for a bit but with the
ows Pro that simply doesn't happen it
just hangs on on the outside of the ear
and thanks to the combination of
lightweight and super soft silicon and
smooth plastic they feel like they're
not even there at all I also noticed
that they stay on incredibly well no
matter what your doing thanks to the
hook design while many in-ear earbuds
tend to want to fall out and now as far
as the question of sound quality because
of the open ear design they naturally
don't sound as loud or as good as other
in-ear earbuds like Apple's airpods Pro
2 which have the speaker drivers super
close right inside of your ear canal
these ones sit above your ears so
there's more distance and space to
travel sacrificing some of the volume
and sound quality but honestly for this
type of design these sound really great
and with a wide Sound Stage especially
when listening at more casual volumes at
around 50 percent where it gives you a
really good balance of sound quality and
bass I also did notice that compared to
regular in-ear earbuds these ones do
leak more sound which is obvious because
they're not in your ear canals and the
speakers are floating above your ears so
that's expect affected and not that big
of a deal and now let's move on to the
final question why and who should
actually make the switch to the ows Pros
well first of all if you're the type of
person who struggles with ear fatigue
from regular in-ear earbuds and you
simply can't find a good pair anywhere
on the market these ones are the perfect
solution instantly eliminating that
fatigue for good on top of that if
you're searching for a great pair of
waterproof earphones for your workouts
or jogs these ones are great since they
stay hooked on and feel like they're not
even there all while keeping your ear
canals free for hearing your
surroundings another reason to try these
out is if you're looking for something
for work something that's non-intrusive
and has incredible battery life to last
more than a full days of work to make
sure they never die on you like so many
other earbuds out there with 16 hours of
battery life you can be sure that
whatever happens these will not die on
you even if you somehow forgot to charge
them lasting up to two full work days
and yes of course these are great for
anyone that just wants to try something
new whether it's for school work or home
use and now let's get into the different
options that you have with the ows Pros
these come in a bunch of finishes like
Misty black porcelain white luminous
titanium Vivid green or pearly Haze pink
so there's a color for everyone and even
better the white pink and green colors
come with their ceramic skin eight layer
coloring process which makes them feel
super smooth like ceramic and as for the
price you can check it out by using the
link down in the description and pinned
comment so you can order them today and
solve your ear fatigue issues for good
if you enjoyed this video go ahead and
subscribe above and check out one of
those two videos right over there thank
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign